[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Zach
Braff this is the third time Zach Braff
the incredible the incomparable The
Talented the wonderful Zach Braff whose
new movie a good person is available on
demand and you should absolutely check
that out we talk about that a little bit
but not so much that it would spoil it
or ruin it and you will love it check
out a good person on Demand right now do
it not right now listen to this right
now and then tonight with popped corn
American popped corn uh but this is the
first time that Zach has been on in
person and it made a huge difference we
totally brow out we came we became
besties in real time and I'm so glad
that you guys get to hear that and enjoy
that I love this conversation I'm so
glad you're here uh only a couple things
to plug up top I'm on the road go to
petehomes.com if you want to come see me
do stand-up New York City is coming up
or actually that just came up by the
time this is out that that just happened
so you missed out but there are new
dates Denver San not San Francisco St
Louis there's lots of stuff coming up go
to petehomes.com all sorts of cities and
then after this tour after the where
were we tour I'm going to start a new
tour called the is this anything tour
which is going to be my new material
tour uh which I'll be working stuff out
that's going to be super fun too so all
of those dates will be on petehomes.com
I'm also at Largo in Los Angeles once a
month go to largo.la.com for that if
you're going to be in La the next one is
August 5th always Incredible One musical
guest and several wonderful comedians
the last one was awesome
go hope and Zach was that one we talk
about that Zach was recently at one and
we that's I think that's how we opened
the episode also if you want to support
the show it means so much try a product
try a Pete's pick we do ads a little bit
differently we do ads for things that I
actually use and actually adore like the
perfect Gene as you guys know I love
perfect jeans I was hanging out with my
friend Katie Lowes and she was like oh
are those your comfort jeans she called
them my comfort jeans which I thought
were funny the perfect Jean and yes they
were because they're the only pants I
wear they look incredible they feel
incredible they're soft as a baby's
bottom they got two percent spandex 2.5
percent rayon for extra comfort and
movement that your man Parts require but
they look like incredible designer jeans
with very very wonderful very very
wonderful craftsmanship I never have to
replace them they stay together they're
well built they fit fantastic they come
in all different cuts and colors and
styles they even have a khaki color
which is my new favorite but it's made
from the same spare your nuts material
they stretch they're so comfy you could
sleep in them but they look so good I've
literally worn them to movie premieres
it doesn't matter they look fantastic no
one needs to know your comfy little
secret so check them out guys it's a
great way to support the show and to
support your lower limbs the perfect
Gene for the Perfectly Imperfect men 20
off when you use code weirdo at checkout
weirdo not weird weirdo so liberate your
lower limbs with the one and only
perfect Jean go to
www.theperfectgene.nyc that's the
perfect Gene j-e-a-n dot NYC and use
code weirdo for 20 off at checkout
you'll be glad you did literally the
only pants that I wear also speaking of
Game Changers I gave some to Zach I
believe on air modern mammals guys I
hate shampoo I never used to wash my
hair that was my my secret I think Zach
says on this episode that was his secret
as well you want your hair to look good
you just don't wash it you rinse it you
don't wash it and Cat my wonderful
friend who cuts my hair last time she
cut it she was like yuck please cut your
hair and that happens I do TV shows and
stuff and there's product in it I gotta
wash it but I also need it to look good
but I didn't want to use regular shampoo
because that meant it was clean sure but
it also looked like dried out fluffy
[__] for two days and so many guy
friends I know we talk about this this
is the problem unmanageable dried out
thin brittle hay on my head terrible so
I didn't know what to do this all
changed for real for real when I found
modern mammals it's now the only shampoo
I use it's like a non-shampoo that
somehow cleans your hair but leaves it
perfect like a perfect hair day it's
still a structure it's got that wave
still got some of its natural moisture
and it stays in place and looks
incredible it's a good hair day in a
bottle it's not about cleaning your hair
it's about cleaning your hair and giving
you a perfect hair day now I wash it
when I want it to look good instead I
used to wash it wait four days for it to
look normal again now I get it on
command my hair regimen is the opposite
of what it used to be uh and now I wash
it every couple days friggin love it uh
over 40 000 guys have switched to this
instead of traditional shampoo you got
to see the reviews for this product
they're insane guys get more excited
about this than anything it blows my
mind once you use it you'll be hooked
for life I've already gotten so many
friends in my life using it they'll
never go back to a regular shampoo and
neither will you and it's a small punk
rock company company they're Grassroots
these were guys who just were fed up
with shampoo and wanted to get it right
specifically for men they have bars for
that no plastic thing which works
fantastic with no fragrance or the
bottle for a more traditional shampoo
experience it's like gray magic mud that
I love and it's six seconds a day that I
spend to get perfect hair do it like
don't wait okay do it go to Modern
mammals.com weird and you can get a
special combo deal and try both the bar
and the bottle for a reduced price of 44
bucks that's the bar and the bottle by
the way both the bar and the bottle last
a really really long time so this one
purchase will be good for a long while
modernmammals.com weird alright
everybody hope to see you on the road
hope to see you at Largo enjoy the
return in person of Zac Brown get into
it it looks like something
and then there was a quick
the person who lives here now my friend
Kate will love that you oh someone lives
there yeah yeah we rent it to our friend
oh I'm sorry it looks a little bit like
no there's something's occurred we need
to get the [__] out of here all right
can I say
director respecter I'm a director
respecter right now I'm respecting a
director yes because if you were doing
set design right and you were like I
want the house to look like something I
don't think that do you think you you
notice though you I I can't go into her
business but yes something like there
was a shift yes and you can tell I can
tell as a filmmaker if I was set
dressing a set I would go we would we
would Scout that and go oh I love how
this is like that you see how that's
like that do that yeah oh do you notice
how this is like like the calendar like
the whiteboards half wiped off yeah I
love that don't do that when we're
scouting locations I'm sure you do this
too when we're Scouting For for shooting
locations I'm always like taking
thousands of pictures and I'm walking
around the production Center like do you
see that do you see how there's the bowl
with the change and four M M's and a
light bulb in the in the kitchen I want
that don't you don't just cut take a
picture of that I want that okay four M
M's
Tim Burton Big Fish they put that that
they put the car in the tree there's a
moment where they put the car in the
tree and this was back when CGI was
pretty bad so he was right to be like
we're not going to CGI yet but he said
something that I always think about Reed
colon film which is you know you don't
know that you know but you know right
here's one the sheets are always too
clean
I know I'm watching a movie because the
sheets look like they were just put on
that bed new spanking sheets here's one
set for stun the streets are always wet
but not the cars just the asphalt
because it looks pretty at night I'm
talking and during a night scene this is
going to bother everyone who doesn't
know this if you're not in the film
industry raise it down this will now
bother you if you're not on the film
industry for the rest of time I'm sorry
um at night it's way prettier if the
streets have some Sheen so they wet down
the asphalt though asphalt is always wet
but it's not like it's rained because if
you look at the cars or or anything else
none of that's wet yeah yeah yeah
no I love this I would argue though two
things one I think people do notice the
the bowl with the I notice if the set
design is so good that I'm like did they
just walk in a house sorry I'm so
excited also don't shave the actors stop
it stop giving them free haircuts
I cast a guy who looked like a [__]
schlub and then he comes in and goes
clean me up I'm gonna be on TV [__] you
yeah I didn't book a guy who's here to
be on TV because you look like a
stand-up comedian who works an open mic
yeah what about the woman going to bed
in full makeup that's very common what
about what about turning on the light
when you answer the phone yeah I was
just watching America
getting hung up on and you hear that
like like no we're not in the 80s I just
watched Tommy Boy and it's to great
effect Tommy Boy by the way holds up
it's fantastic uh and Rob Lowe is
pretending to be on the phone and as
he's putting the phone down he goes
but it's perfect you
don't cover your breasts yeah I don't
care look I'm not trying to see breasts
I'm saying there's other ways than to
have the woman sit up with the sheet to
her thing that's not how we're your
movie by the way a good person very
intimate the intimacy scenes are very
legit and real and well blocked I don't
even want to say blocked because they
don't feel blocked yeah they feel like
intimacy yeah they're laughing yeah
there's like natural it feels like these
people have had sex before it's not like
a you know what I mean they've been
dating for years you don't need to show
a thing no in fact it's funny when you
look back at these 80s movies there was
always a [__] scene it was like if it
was an R if it was R it was like when's
the [__] scene yeah yeah isn't that
funny looking back now and when and when
it's not a thing anymore obviously
there's sex if it's if it's if it feels
Justified for the most part yeah but but
but then then they always kind of cut
away you don't sit in the [__] scene
right
those 80s movies you did yeah
Terminator one yeah
full cupping yeah of breasts always
always Venetian blinds with the light
coming through
cops were always peering out of them and
boobies were always glistening under
them Venetian blinds were the only
blinds in the 1980s I think now you can
yeah it was hard to have a sex scene in
the 80s without Venetian blinds anyone
who [__] in an 80s movies had light
coming through their Venetian blinds
that's what motels had
no I think it was just a style of light
that you'd get this nice pattern we call
it a gobo you'd get a a nice Gobo
pattern I've been to gobo
don't wait till you can afford it go to
Gobo I'm jumping I have so much to talk
to you about I'm worried about getting
it in 90 minutes I will do one more
One More film thing
but like we're doing film things
remember okay one more uh suitcases put
some minimum weigh them down a little
bit that is such a I feel like maybe
we've done this before we haven't but
you and I are so similar in so many ways
cups put something in it yeah I've been
a victim of that I've seen scrubs
episodes where I clearly don't have
anything in the cup
I like the Hugo I don't have anything no
no cause I'm at home he doesn't have
anything no I've learned these things
this many years into the business I
always say to the prop person can you
please put weight in the suitcase can
you please put coffee in the coffee cup
yeah um all right I'll just grab with
the bang and say I abhor
when they remove the rear view mirror in
the car uh can I yes I am that for the
hardest succent and say who the [__] do
you think you're making a movie for
removing the headrest headrest as well
you think you can remove the headrest
headrest and rear view mirror and I'm
just gonna be watching the movie and go
I guess they just don't have head wraps
yes I guess they don't have a rear view
mirror and no rear view mirror and
they're just cruising with no problem I
hate it get out of my life I have to say
it in production meetings like when you
when you get to the talking about the
car scene do not please do not remove
the rear view mirror well you're going
okay that was my other point when you're
going to let me ask you this we should
do a podcast called things Pete and Zach
don't like about movies don't like as
movie conventions I mean I think people
enjoy I watched a YouTube recently that
was like it was like seven things you uh
I'm writing a movie that's a little bit
like liar liar so I was like watching
Liar Liar Youtube right I love script
analysis I love it it's like free film
school it's awesome very good very good
and very good for uh free access to to
Young The Young Folks coming up I know
are you kidding me you couldn't do that
no you can literally go like what's a
three-act structure and not only will
someone tell you they'll tell you and
it'll be like entertaining it'll be
beautifully produced and they'll cut the
fat and they're jumping around and
they're making you laugh it's like it's
cool like Film School even film school
would be a snooze it would be like
School wasn't as soon as I went yeah you
did yeah it's a snooze the only thing I
remember the only thing I remember was
make only the way I remember learning at
all
was making things of course the the most
valuable thing was that they had a a
room filled with equipment that you
could borrow from a very hostile uh
group of people you
minding it out like yeah it was like
tough breath yeah sign that out you're
not at the level where you can get the
16 millimeter camera let me see you load
the magazine yeah nope nope
I just what I news you couldn't I knew
you just couldn't do it you just exposed
the whole film's worth of dumb of me
shooting my own yeah so far
I am you didn't like film school I liked
it the people I loved Northwestern I
really enjoyed going there
um but I would say to anyone who asked
me
do not if you want to go have a liberal
arts education of course have that
experience yeah but if you are one
thousand percent positive you want to
make movies just go don't go to film
school go PT Anderson go QT go make
movies go PA go go pee well I don't know
I go to Pennsylvania you mean go be a
production go to Pennsylvania no I went
I was a production assistant go beat
Paul Thomas Anderson because he dropped
out of film school and Quentin Tarantino
didn't go to film school yeah I think
the thing you need especially now that
the gear is so much more accessible back
then it was also like I don't know they
have all this gear and they're going to
give me access to it in classes now it's
all so accessible and and so much
cheaper and easier let me ask you go
ahead this on your I'm here to answer
any sandwich put this on your sandwich
and then I'll watch you eat it okay
how do you feel about inciting incidents
happens on what is it 15 30. oh new
world is 30. I don't follow much of that
I mean does it end up happening anyway
of course yeah and I find that if you
don't do it for those wondering we're
talking about classic film structure
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt here's
an example of
I think if you you fall into that if
you're telling a decent story because
we've all anything we've all ever seen
follows that structure isn't that weird
it is isn't it weird that like story it
like does have like a DNA like it's a
thing well what happens is if you go and
test your movie and you haven't and
you're not entering the new world in 30
minutes the audience will be like it's
slow yeah and they don't know why
necessarily unless they're in the film
industry but what they're responding to
is their entire life of conditioning
that at 30 minutes in the first 30 was
establishing the way things are and then
then there's an inciting innocent and
then at 30 minutes in if I enter a new
world so I I go in the red bill I take
the red pill it's on page 30 by the way
I'm sure but but I'm not sure because I
I resent the one minute one page thing
when I write you're listening to this
and you've never heard what were uh see
heard this if this is boring just start
masturbating well this is boring
masturbate anyway just have your hand on
it while we talk we can't see you you
should just be going yeah especially if
you're in your car especially if you're
a lady no cleanup just do it oh my God
it just began can you imagine if there
was Zero consequence you could just
I never thought about the zero
consequences zero consequence I dated a
woman who could make herself without
touching it so she'd just be at the
beach like squeaks no yeah yeah
little little one I want to hear that
podcast I do too you're on it
I wanted to tell your audience that uh
here's the easiest way to watch it in
movies
um when you're watching a movie
um the first 30 minutes will be this is
the way things have been
and then and then something happens and
now I have to go on some sort of a quest
or some sort of new thing is going to
happen like the red pill is the ultimate
example
um you'll watch and almost to the second
that will be 30 minutes in that's right
I Val and I she's a screenwriter as well
we like to just look at we'll we'll just
if I pause it when something big happens
and unpause it she knows I was just
checking the time because I want to see
where it is around 30. but the Matrix is
a good one the other ones we're missing
is there's a call so that Morpheus wants
to meet you and in in The Matrix the the
refusing the call is is a big step I
don't follow that at all I I believe you
but no but but I'm I'm saying if it
happens in your movie if I'm in a good
person she misuses the call she puts the
the pamphlet on her that's refusing oh
wow see that's cool that you did that
enough that's what I'm doing for fun no
I think that's cool I know I actually
gave me a little bit of Goosebumps on my
arm isn't that fun because here's the
thing I think if you're writing a giant
Studio Movie for a ton of money you you
have an obligation to follow that
structure probably to the T because
you're trying to maximize your audience
I think when you're telling a personal
story that's more independent tell just
tell the story as good as possible now
what's going to happen just
intrinsically is that you're going to
follow some of those conventions because
that's how that's every movie we've all
ever seen right for the most part it's
like it's even your dreams sort of like
your better dreams have like some sort
of float even the way you tell a story
if you come home to your wife and you I
have the craziest [__] story to tell
you what happened today it's gonna
follow a structure it even follows a
modern structure let's say I come into
your apartment and I just go yeah I
you're not gonna believe what just
happened to me I just got cut off by
again throw a chicken in my window and
then I go sorry let me start at the
beginning yeah that's movies that's
movies now yeah you put on a movie now
it starts in the action so you're just
like yeah five minutes earlier I should
probably tell you how I got here yeah
exactly the freeze frame it's
Ratatouille he's jumping out the window
with the cookbook on his head and goes
let's back up well because you have to
wait a minute now more than ever you
don't get a lazy first 30 minutes well
that's why speaking of Paul Thomas
Anderson when I watched do you really
like Paul Thomas Sanders well he's only
come up twice give me another 45 minutes
let's see how we do but did you see
licky Pete's licorice pizza um I did
that movie I really enjoyed it and I I'm
pretty sure that movie had almost no
attempt at what we're talking about yes
like it opens if you are delighted by
like incredible acting and dialogue and
an interesting camera move which is
asking a lot let me put it let me put
this to you I watch uh Fast and Furious
movies like I got this was years ago but
I've never seen one I got stoned and I
was like I'm just gonna watch it Fast
and the Furious movie and I couldn't
Zach everything look no disrespect to
Vinnie d but I'm just saying yeah the
amount is okay he's gonna be okay he's
gonna be fine yeah I got a billion
dollars
while you've begun
your sins I made time billion dollars
I honestly don't know Vin Diesel's work
so I don't know if I do a pretty good
Morgan Freeman watching that sounds like
Morgan Freeman go ahead here's Morgan
Freeman you're a really good Morgan
Freeman well okay we'll see
no there's the pressure's on you do lots
of good things I don't know if it's more
I don't know
hello Zach it's me Morgan calling I was
very happy to see that the movie came
out
it was very good and I was pleased
enjoying your impression but this is
Morgan Freeman oh wow I think you're
hello Pete this is Morgan Freeman like
David Attenborough I think we should do
interviews Morgan Freeman I want to talk
about the Penguins my every time the
movie because your movie is intense like
anybody that hasn't seen a good person
go watch it yeah please watch a good
push I'm gonna I'm not gonna say push
emotionally so it's successful as a
movie you have to stay with it for the
first 30 40 minutes but why that seems
like you're implying that that's gonna
take some efforting only
let's put it this way I mean this as a
compliment it's succeeding as a movie
and it's very heavy yes and then around
the time that morgie free starts kind of
coming more in the story you go oh it's
Redemption yeah you think is he making
Babel remember Babel
is this a babble is Zach just going like
don't forget like the world's [__]
crazy crazy okay that's good advice to
people the movie is not um the movie has
humor in it it uses humor all the time
but it is certainly do you think I like
this [__]
it's certainly
[Laughter]
yours is great by the way it's certainly
uh an intense film it features two very
uh
heartbreaking performances by Florence
Pew and Morgan Freeman oh my God her
share yeah forget it yeah it's not a
spoil there she has a little more
there's a lot of great monologues and
she has one that you're like
like try not to cry it's an incredibly
successful movie she is uh astonishing
but at the moment you're talking about
is is one of the most powerful
things I've ever seen I guess I'm I I
know I'm biased but [__] hell that
performance in that moment is one of the
best things I've ever seen oh speed
agree but also one of the things you do
what's speed agree I agree very quickly
it's something we used to say Laura
guten and I a great writer by the way so
when we were in writer's rooms would go
speed agree it means I accept your pitch
we don't have to talk about it are you
always in a good mood no I love you seem
like such a happy human being this is
like that joke you're like a dose of
[__] serotonin I'm sunlight I love
this this is like that show you'd agree
Lions there I saw Louie say it I Scandal
noted but on on the show Louis he's
telling a street joke and they'll notice
you have all these little tourettes you
have a podcast you have a podcast you
have to say Scandal noted I don't I'm
gonna I'm gonna adopt it we don't know
how to talk about things like that
that's how you just skip it look the
whole podcast would just be like I
understand the Nuance of it you have to
just be like oh because I don't know I'm
often asked about films that have
influenced me uh yeah and I'm Scandal
noted Annie Hall I don't know how to
talk about anything
was like animal note so Annie Hall was
like one of the most pivotal films in my
whole childhood it was my father's
favorite movie my father would project
it somehow he got a print and we weren't
like a rich family with a movie theater
he got a print somehow and was
projecting it on the living room wall at
a dinner party this is how much the
movie impacted my life and I'd go do
press for a good person and I don't know
I'm not allowed to talk about
understandably Woody Allen I get it but
I need the expression Scandal noted
because it's weird to remove it from my
entire history I completely agree and as
people that I know that have complicated
relationships with family members we all
know the gear Scandal noted I love my
dad Scandal noted you know what I'm
saying right we know that Nuance it's
not new but I don't know we're trying to
bring it into pop culture I like the
Scandal noted thing but I don't know on
my podcast on my podcast we usually just
skip it or cut it if we because we we
don't want to upset anyone we're in the
business of helping that you'll spend an
hour and a half with us and laugh and
smile and we don't want to upset anyone
I understand but at the same time I do
find ourselves myself going oh let's
just cut that like it doesn't you know
what's the point you're doing risk
reward but
right I mean the risk of keeping it in
is upsetting people and the reward is
very small well what you're what I like
about your little Scandal noted thing is
it goes I know what you're thinking but
also we want to express ourselves freely
well you don't want to Gaslight anyone
too I I would wager that one of the
worst things about trauma is the denial
of the trauma I've said this a million
times but when I would watch a zombie
movie as a kid it wasn't the zombies
that were scary said no one believed the
person that was like they're zombies
right like you escape and you go on a
house and everyone's having dinner
you're like there's zombies and they're
like all right Dan and they're all dead
ten minutes later that so what I'm
saying is
to acknowledge pain conflict tragedy
trauma yes and just say I know got it
makes it not a non-gaslight now we're
not acting like Woody Allen is not a
complicated person or that I can say
Louis he could say Louis CK said this
joke say Scandal noted okay yeah I like
it I'm gonna steal it if that's okay do
I say sealing it if it's a gift did you
make it you'll notice there's no gift
receiving there did you make your keep
it where's my gift bag this show feels
you do get the show feels fancy enough
that we that you'd get gift bags modern
mammals we have the same hair type that
shampoo is Gonna Knock your dick off do
you know that um you sold me something
that I on your podcast yeah I know you
love you love to you
I just gotta I just got a couple I don't
think I got the brand of advertised but
what I did get is one of the um all
everything you need to eat yeah you got
kachava you sold me you successfully
sold me kachava but you and I are
similar dudes this is what you want
shake that up and drink it I have a
really good um self-help book for you
too that's like 70 years old what's it
called
[Music]
because 70 years ago I got to look it up
it's come in the 1950s a 1950 self-help
book yeah it's like you're not tell that
Dame to shut our Yap get in the car this
is the first public
um smoke a cigarette do a belt of scotch
and you'll feel like a man again you'd
think it would be that you honestly
salute the flag
I want to tell your audience give the
finger to most of Europe here you go how
to stop worrying
and start living by Dale Carnegie Dale
Carnegie wrote the more famous How to
Win Friends and Influence okay
um now I you I listen to podcasts and I
um
I'm drawn to things about anxiety and
worry and this book came up a few times
and I thought that's funny it's from
like 1950. how could it be relevant yeah
and it's I'm I'm I want to sell it to
you I want to read it because I find it
more helpful than most and um and I it's
because he's like let's get down to
brass tacks boys
well it's just Universal truths yeah the
things that are causing us to worry and
the friend and the the framing in our
mind of the way data comes through our
eyeballs into our brain every day and
how we receive it is the same from from
1950 yeah uh yeah occasionally he'll say
some word that you're like we don't use
that word anymore right not a racist
word but just like an expression that
you're like right
um but it's just funny and fascinating
that his tips and tricks and and uh
anecdotes are are are more relevant than
ever
yes I'm with you I I think truth is
truth is truth and we're kind of doing a
lot of rediscovering yes and that
stoicism as an example yeah it's pulling
from stoicism which is which is now
everywhere and wonderful and helpful but
he's referencing you know uh you know
Marcus Aurelius uh in in the 1950s how
frustrating is it that Marcus really has
figured these things out yeah and we we
still want to find out for ourselves but
stoicism to me is reduced to like you
can't control what happens but you can
control how you respond yeah to what
happens yes I think of you almost every
time I exercise because you said the
other two times you're on the podcast it
was the only thing that came up both
times and I was like that's a big breath
big breath what is it a big breath big
breath loves that speed agree what is it
it's uh exercise would put me out of
business is what your therapist said
yeah so whenever I get on my uh whatever
exercise thing I'm like this is this is
mental health yeah it is everybody was
saying that but why did I have to figure
that out I've reframed it in my brain
for thinking of it like you know you
think you you if one takes any
depressant like think of this just as
another piece of your medication yeah
you have to exercise or you're not going
to be as happy
it's insane I've said this on the show
before but I got a Peloton I noticed the
character in a good person I have one
too yeah writing a Peloton and I was
like I wonder if Zach has a Peloton I
also wanted to know if you do EFT which
is the thing that Molly Shannon I'm
sorry
well she makes fun because she doesn't
understand it I'm I did it once
um my stepmother is very into it and she
learned how to do it and I was having a
very stressful moment and I happened to
be with her and she starts doing it with
me yeah and I'm rolling my eyes and
being like this is like weird Witchcraft
and it did in fact calm me down yeah and
so tell the people what it is because no
one knows what we're talking about it's
um emotional Freedom technique well it's
tapping on different
um pressure points on your your body
um and there's plenty of YouTube videos
where you can watch people doing it and
talking you through it or if you can
afford to do so find someone in your
where you live who does it I'm very
interested to do it um I just happen to
have a stepmother who had learned and um
it's it's um it's tapping in several
places on on your face and on your chest
and uh think of it almost like
acupuncture but doing it with your
fingers yeah without a needle yeah and
then there's a there's a component the
way that I learned it trying to remember
it's this this this did you find did you
find help from it oh my God I do this
one all the time is that one this has
one and it just it seems It's like
[__] what's his name in in the
Scorsese movie uh
it's just a simple thing just give
yourself a handful of Taps on the chest
like this and it kind of calms you down
Val's always putting her hand Dishonored
to like a gentle hand on chest I I find
that I had an acting coach for scenes
where you have to cry they're like just
put a hand on your chest and say like
it's safe you can you can open up here
it's okay crazy oh yeah it works it
feels nice if you're doing sort of yoga
or something like that and someone will
say like I put a hand on your on your on
your heart and a hand on your belly and
that just feels nice getting in your
body I think I'm gonna say for guys like
us I think we're top down guys you think
about the world
you out there thinking about are you are
you kind of in your body
I mean am I in my header
bottom up means like body first like
feeling feeling grounded feeling in your
body sensory and top down is like I
think about how this is going more than
oh I'm a huge thinker I'm a huge Warrior
I really this book is is I've always had
anxiety I've always I've had OCD I've
been diagnosed with OCD I think I always
see I don't even [__] I'm questioning
at all now but I I definitely am someone
who I've gone through my whole life
thinking everyone worries and over
things things at this level and it's
only like 48 years old and I'm like oh
no it really isn't everyone which by the
way
going back to Annie Hall that scene
where he's in the line at the movie
theater and he addresses the guy behind
him yeah that was our party in the USA
you know what I mean
what do you mean the way people feel
about the song Party in the USA I feel
about that being able to grab Marshall
mcluhan from behind a poster I just mean
I'm like you overthinking analyzing what
does it mean what does that mean how did
it go did I do it right and that moment
where Woody Allen addresses is anybody
else hearing this guy like an and I my
whole life
it's wonderful that we were able to love
movies because popcorn is the loudest
movie snack slurping on straws back in
the 80s it was totally in bounds to be
like that's gotta hurt I remember we saw
uh the the Kevin Costner Robin Hood and
like first of all you had to have a joke
for every preview everybody had a joke
bring a pillow you know stuff like
yelling stuff out everybody and then
this guy my brother and I still say this
to this day it's the opening scene in
the movie where he's in the jail and
he's going to get cut off Robin Hood
prince of Thieves yeah it fades up and
the guy goes
Bangladesh he just yells Bangladesh and
then the Chiron comes in and says
Jerusalem and then he goes Jerusalem
like he took he took the correction I
can't go to I can't go to the movies
this is what I'm saying I'm too
sensitive but the whole world is like
that I don't think they are I think that
oh I don't mean the whole world is like
that I mean the whole world is like that
to me oh yes I'm saying it took a long
time for me to go
um not everyone has this particular
um neuroses yeah
did I say this to you last time I was
like art is highly sensitive people
reporting back to the rest of the group
what reality is like for them wow that's
beautiful isn't that right you didn't
make that up today I made that up was
that Marcus Aurelius
Seneca
wait say it again I like that art is
highly sensitive people reporting back
to the rest of the group what reality is
like for them for them and what's crazy
is though the rest of the group relates
because there's a part of them that can
kind of well yeah they see if they made
a piece of art they they would create
something different or it would overlap
but they see ideally if they've come to
see your art because they like your art
they see a piece of themselves in it I
did in you I so loved seeing your
stand-up show I saw it right before you
did it live that's right will it be live
before before or after this airs it'll
be out after okay well everyone
obviously your audience is gonna watch
but it means a lot that you liked it I
loved it yeah and I'm not just saying
that I've been thinking about it I've
seen other stand-ups since and not like
them as much as you and I I thought it
was I thought you were so funny thanks
and I thought it was everything I like
about a stand-up uh hour or so in that
you made me laugh but then you moved me
but not you didn't do too much you you
used a little just a little a little bit
of something I feel well we're similar
you had good insights in addition to
being humorous you you made me think
about things in a new way I just thought
it was masterful thanks man to give you
a compliment in kind because I do think
we're similar and I would even say you
influenced me uh with Garden State is
like
there's a certain embarrassment you have
to get over
sharing what you think is interesting
question mark like your character is a
good person as well
say
interesting things and there's a certain
vulnerability I'll give you an example
the guy in the bar it's not a spoiler he
says I can't I won't be able to do the
line you will he goes we're not even
half as much of the people you some
you're more than you are more of the
you're more like what you think we are
than we're half of what like there's
this brilliant line like that I probably
ruined it now you probably couldn't even
you [__] it up so much that I'm trying
to think of what the line is but what
I'm saying is you you lay these lines in
and there's a risk there's a risk to
like being clever I always think of
Fight Club where he goes how's that
working out he goes what being clever
it's risky yeah but when you can do it
like a like a restaurant that does put
Thanksgiving in a chilled dish and
you're just like God damn that was
Thanksgiving but it doesn't ruin the
reality yeah it doesn't make every
character talk the same like that guy
said something clever in that guy's
voice right so you did this guy is also
a point in being a very clever person
who never got out of the dot local dive
bar right and I find that sort of person
interesting I have friends at home in
Jersey that are so smart well they're
lacking and not lacking that sounds like
they're missing something I they but
what I'm saying they're lacking isn't
necessarily good
I'm gonna put it as a question you and I
have a compulsion I'm going to say I
have a compulsion to if I say that I'm
like I have to share that if I say art
is highly sensitive people reporting to
the rest of the group what life is like
for them I'm like I gotta shout that
from the rooftops some people are wired
differently they can have a very clever
or brilliant or an interesting they can
have a great song in their heart or a
movie idea and they're just kind of like
not as neurotically compulsed obsessed
obsessed yeah my let me put it to you my
[__] gets me out of bed what a gift
it'll wake me up it'll make you go like
get up more than a flight will yeah like
it goes are we that you're doing that I
I I felt that when I was watching your
show I thought we're so we're so lucky
that people like you are are are are
working so hard to to do a performance
like that well I feel the same way and
where where are you with your work are
you still composed compulsed is that a
word compulsed do you feel compulsion
there you go to do it like because I
feel a little exhausted after you do the
whole cycle of something I don't know if
you're if you're someone who can do your
hour and then want to go right back and
start again I don't know I have a post
party yeah postpartum for sure I just
texted someone last night I was like
like how was the special I was like it's
good you have a postpartum and then you
have a vulnerability hangover where
you're like oh no now they're gonna see
it even though I I stand by it I'm gonna
promote the hell out of it I want people
to see it but then I'm like oh they're
gonna see it like this is weird yeah I
feel that too I don't have the impulse
to go right again or uh direct I'm going
to direct direct other people's things
we can direct shrinking um um season two
once the strike is over with Bill
Lawrence that's great
um but in terms of like sitting and
staring at the blank blinking cursor I
don't feel a compulsion to do that right
away I did start something
um that I'll go back to but I just it's
so hard for me to make something and
then release it and then beg the world
to see it and I just you kind of want to
go fetal for a while after completely
did you what did you watch the Arnold
documentary no the three part there's
just one part that really stood out
where he was like on the actors you know
they don't want to promote their movies
I go out I promote and I was like that's
what it is this guy like is
unembarrassed by all of it you know what
I mean he's not the actor who will be in
the movie and then doesn't want to do
the Tories like I go to Bangladesh I go
to [__] India I go to Jerusalem
so much more
uh do you feel as someone who does uh
all three things as well that uh that
the the most vulnerable one is writing
interesting I if you attend acting I
would have quickly speed agreed because
writing to me is like uh going into the
weird cave and there's like a there's
like a cauldron and I'm like I'm sorry
it was the spell I was under the spell
and even if it's like weird or strange
I'll be like it came out of The Cauldron
you know where his acting is like that
was your choice like you went like
you know and like everyone's like well
like you mentioned shrinking what would
Jason ziegel have done he probably would
have done that more interestingly or or
better with writing I'm just sort of
like
I have a strange confidence with it
where I'm like I'm doing it exactly how
I would do it I like that and no one
would teach that in a course for others
I'm shocked you are one of the voices
you're one of the choices people are
ripping you off you know or let's put it
in a positive people have been you've
shaped a generation of writers people
that wouldn't have thought of doing it
that I'm sorry I know Garden State was a
long time ago I'm just saying like
that's a seminal it's like Goodwill
Hunting you know what I mean it's like
oh [__]
guys like I know you're a show business
guy but so is [__] Ben and Matt you
know what I mean right but we can do it
like it had a certain
our voice was important our stories were
important like we can we can do this and
I think that had a ripple effect so it's
not strange to me but I'm curious how it
feels for you writing
um
I'm very I I I I love having written
I find it um I find I find um it's very
hard to get my butt in the chair but
then when I get when I get going on
something and I'm excited about it then
then I'm off to the races it's just um
I I I don't want to say it doesn't it
doesn't come easy to me because that's
not true the truth is that it's a battle
for me to uh put my ass in the chair
yeah
I'm almost hesitating to say this
because I'm in the middle of an
experiment and I can't tell you the long
term of it but I've started have I'm I'm
calling it a dictionarying so I hate
starting writing like I love being in
the flow but it's really hard I'm not
staring up at the mountain God I can't
stand it I've had a movie idea for it's
like my get out at this point I've had
it for like 10 years
it's completely outlined it's like ready
to go just write it like that that's the
hard part what's the story like for me
that's Harbor dialogue's fun you know
these guys yeah it's easy when you go uh
all right I need you to write a scene
homes and Zach Braff earn a coffee shop
they're discussing whether they're going
to rob the bank or not yeah and uh and
there's a charactery waitress that comes
over and she keeps offering them decaf
but they want regular coffee right go I
can write that scene 10 times yeah
that's right and in the reader it says
she'll be important later can we add
that to the waitress the waitress Betty
she'll be important later remember her
remember her do you put little um I do
fun sassy comments in your action lines
I do yeah you strike me as a guy who
does that I love having fun I love I
love being flowery in my descriptors I
don't care it's like there ha it has to
have [__] to it you know what I'm saying
it has to be like Cockiness it has to be
like
yeah billowing billowing that's fine I
read I read so many scripts uh as a
actor and director that aren't mine that
I that are hard to get through and they
might be incredible films it's just that
that love and fun isn't necessarily in
the action lines I agree
I've started to do it a little bit more
just because I I think gosh who's ever
reading this has read so many scripts
and and throughout history
at least the ones I've read yeah what's
great is going to be what's made not
necessarily what's in the non-dialogue
action lines yeah and I've tried at
least with a good person I try to be a
little more fun with it why not there
was a script on The Blacklist that I
always think about where he would write
uh fade the [__] in was it was the first
one though I know it's a little too much
calm down calm down did that movie get
made are we talking about the name of
that movie no I'm just talking about a
movie people talked about and that movie
that movie was was a serious man in that
movie
well let me tell you addiction Guardians
of the Galaxy part two
um have you seen Paddington too
you mean the perfect movie I know that
that's a meme and stuff I think it's the
most beautiful movie I've ever seen in
my life it's a perfect movie I finally
had to watch the Paddington movies
because there were so many jokes about
how Paddington 2 was brilliant I agree
it became a thing and I was sick and I
was I had strep throaters for me and I
was like you know what I'm gonna buckle
down and watch these [__] movies
Paddington 2 was one of the most
beautiful movies I've ever seen uh buddy
is that is that uh the ring because I'm
gonna throw my hat in it um Paddington
one is also excellent yeah does take it
up a notch I agree they're making
Paddington they're building off the back
of Paddington one which did a lot of the
heavy lifting but when he's oh my God
spoilers for those guys listen but he
went I just started sobbing when he was
underwater Oh no
it's it's the perfect you know the bad
version is
it's also so beautiful it's Toy Story uh
Toy Story 4 where the aliens very subtly
they're at the dump and the alien toys
very subtly run off and then they're
about to get incinerated and then the
aliens save them but it's a very key
moment as a director like how do we
subtly show that the aliens go with the
car and they run off right you're like I
buy that we've had three movies of them
being obsessed with claws they ran out
for the clock but you don't you don't
note it you don't make a meal of it
there's not no hard angle that follows
them they just kind of run off and then
they save the bad version is you're
watching an action movie and the hero is
running and he's it's me and you okay
it's in our bank heist movie Betty's
gone and we robbed the bank and then you
run off and you go I just saw a DVD of
Scrubs and we're like that seems kind of
heavy-handed and you're like I didn't
even want to say but I wrote it but you
ran off to go get the DVD then I run off
and then I get cornered and the bad guys
are going to kill me and they're about
to kill me and then bang their body
drops in reveal it's you right it's
Betty
better
we gotta write this movie
later she was important pretty soon
after
sure better in a moment
buddy I didn't even get that it should
be Betty that was so soon that Betty
shot you that's actually 45 in the
movies
okay good but um we have one ticket sold
over here in Paddington the fact that
his friends are betraying him and you
buy that they would betray him and then
they changed that books are just so
pretty I love Artful films that that
that that actually don't forget that we
need to have a beautiful story
degree uh speed agree I'm also going to
say this so I watched the Aaron Sorkin
master class uh on screen did you uh did
was it beneficial to your writing yes
but I can not but
and I can summarize it pretty quickly
the things that I really took from it
and one of them was
um the solution has to be in the
beginning
he says very articulately you can't have
them go in the third act everything's
gone to [__] what about the magic lasso
you can't right you can't everyone hates
that and then he realized there was a
magic lasso that would open a new
dimension you have to see it at the
beginning
because I really pictured it oh you're
standing pants on oh a tornado goes by I
thought you were opening up my [__]
like a balloon and blowing into it you
mean a
ham know your ass blows off like it was
a separate plastic piece like
manufactured differently yeah I no
longer have an ass
and you just don't have one and and six
months later you go you know I don't
miss I don't know what no six don't let
her go I'm not a feeling well I'm a
little packed I I don't know what it is
it might be that fact that I haven't
defecated I don't know but it is but it
might be that I don't have it yeah
Scandal acknowledge
Scandal noted he does it he doesn't he
does the speech hello
it doesn't work when you do it you know
um what is it Scandal noted Scandal
noted
um here's what he said to me once
Scandal noted who did what can I say
Woody Allen said to me Scandal notes
yeah I was doing the play Bullets Over
Broadway
um um the Broadway musical version of
his fantastic film Scandal noted and
each night he would give me when the
previews when the
when a joke wouldn't play when a laugh
line wouldn't play the next day he would
give me
card with a new line to try that night
oh wow so he blamed the line
that's good he sided with you yeah I
mean it's it's it's it's what a comedy
writer in theater should be doing
sitting in the back of the house and
when something's not playing
um trying something new I agree or you
could write a big old p on that script
you know what that stands for don't you
what performance
I don't think he ever said it was my
performance well that's what's making
him rare that's what I'm saying he's
siding with you are you saying you get
cards that have a p on them as a writer
and knowing this as an actor it's brutal
if you're at a table read and you hear
everyone go
they just wrote A P because you went
talk about Taco Tuesday oh I never knew
that right what I saw in Scrubs was um
uh when it gets a laugh there'd be a
check check is good but p is different
yeah and then also you'd see Bill do a
big cross through it which meant like
[__] that joke that's right that's right
but I never heard a p
I would see a lot of peas really my
favorite note story but like in on on
crashing yeah other things I did but I
remember one time I was shooting a scene
in the West Village and Jed Camp Judd
was directing and he came up and he was
holding a script and I looked at a
script why what am I doing nothing good
is on that script he's directing us and
I look at the script and just he wrote
in the margins Pete needs to be funnier
oh my God but whatever how is that not
Soul crushing to you because he's right
the character we were always trying to
find the level that my character was
supposed to be funny in fact I
fantasized about after I'm dead they'll
do the funny cut of crashing because
every scene I did like a balls out every
riff I could think of take just not what
we did because he's supposed to be
depressed he's supposed to be saved he's
supposed to be he's supposed to be new
he can't be coming in and being funny is
it funnier than not funnier than Bill
Burr but I can't be keeping Pace with
Bill Burr I'm an open Miker I disagree
with that choice I like you you can
direct season four come into
Roku can I tell you coming to a Sunoco
gas station pump yes 30 second episodes
two apps have you not heard the new
thing that um we're doing we're doing 30
second episodes on gas pumps now I hate
that they're taking our Consciousness at
the gas pump if there was one place left
to look at the wind and the trees it was
the [__] gas pump and now it's
someone being like no right they were
losing check I want to get to the fact
that crashing was incredible and I loved
it but it makes no sense to leave jokes
on the floor I'm sorry to um the king of
comedy Judd Apatow but I disagree with
that choice well you wanna you wanna
email them I'm available I'm available
for crashing so you say when I die in
untimely no I don't even want to say
that you can do the uh the people the
Jewish first the Jewish version yeah
same story what if we did what if we did
the exact same scripts but just switched
everything to Judaism
yeah and Jessica my stepson will play
herself again if we can do but you see
your characters are never like overtly
Jewish even though your middle name is
Israel how do you remember that
screen camera which brings me back to
Scandal noted uh oh yeah what he told
you
so one night I get to the line in front
of 2500 people my brain is going [__]
what's the new joke what's the new joke
I can't remember it it's Panic of course
and in my panic I skipped the whole
thing the the setup and the and the
punchline
and the next day I see him coming up to
me
and I really don't you hear the oboe you
hear the oboe please
you hear the clarinet and you turn it's
him I heard I heard it
very very bluesy
[Music]
clarinet note talk about something
nobody wants to tell somebody Woody the
clarinet
it's not cool man anyway
so he says to me uh I said I'm sorry uh
I forgot I I panicked and I forgot and
he goes yeah
you'll probably get a a bigger laugh if
you
actually say it on stage
[Music]
Scandal noted Scandal noted can I finish
the Paddington yes so the this is not a
three-act structure conversation
what a thrill this is like a Tarantino
conversation and yeah Jumping All Around
I agree and yet if this was different
The Listener would know something was
wrong
there's something unspeakable well that
is correct what the listener likes in
this form is to people who like each
other jumping all around because they
have shared interests agree and I would
hope I would add to that they enjoy
listening to kindness I actually think
that's what on a deeper level yeah
you're a very kind man but I like having
an opportunity and a space to be loving
and kind of fusive don't hold back a
compliment you know what I mean create a
safe place for each other I think that's
a nice I think that's the reason I'm
drawn to you is I do and also I
mentioned Rich Roll a podcaster who I
really liked a lot there is just a I
think I said to him when I was on the
podcast it feels like there's this
there's so much negativity on the
interwebs and now I feel like there's
this draw at least with my own brain to
be pulled towards kind voices okay I
have a lot on this
real fast because I've said it a billion
times
you're gonna love it though there was a
study sorry everybody but if you've
heard it before I've heard it every time
you just say there was a study so there
was this day uh these people walk down
the hall they get to the animal there's
there's magnetic poetry and they have
the make poetry with the magnetic poetry
and they leave everyone thinks they're
studying what kind of poems do people
make well based on their income but it's
not that they're studying how quickly
they left the room based on the words
they gave them so the one group the
first group gets words like Swift quick
rapid rushed and they walked out like 30
faster than the group that were loaded
with the with the impetus what is that
it does not taste good it's just I was
expecting water is it is this one of
your sponsors yeah cucumber lime it's so
amazing hilarious
hilarious that's good super NS
don't cut that
I won't cut it don't you cut that I
won't cut it you mean the real can I
tell you why it might tastes a little
funky no now that I if someone said hey
it's cucumber lime I'd be like I'm ready
I see but I was expecting water
now that you've said it it tasted like
water had gone bad cucumber does taste
like water it turned into a a melon of
some sort yeah it tastes like um I've
never had that flavor it's nice though I
don't hate it Nirvana super NS I love it
it has hmb in it which helps you keep
from losing your muscle you're such a
good salesman with your um with the
things you you promote you mentioned
that before because you told me on your
podcast you sort of well now we take it
a bit more seriously because we have
real sponsors that we that we don't want
to uh upset yeah we want to do a good
job for them because they really believe
in the show and they support the show
yeah but we used to you know not take it
issues but I listened to your podcast
like this [__] guy could sell me
anything and he did I want you to have a
magic button does this really do
anything oh my [__] god it's the
[__] best this relaxes you it takes
the edge off your caffeine gives you
nootropics to help you think and it
gives you a little bit of green tea and
you notice it I love it all right for
real alcohol no yeah do long
it's been five six years did that
totally change your life
um no I I would be I mean yes the you
know what I mean
you weren't a big drinker before no I
was it's not the thing it's like
quitting drinking does change your life
but it's all the work that does to get
you to the place where you can quit
drinking does that make sense oh you did
a program no it would be short selling
it short
love
um support friendship creative
fulfillment spirituality recognizing
what wasn't working but but having a
foundation that allowed me to recognize
that something wasn't working these are
all things that led to me to quit
drinking so to say quitting drinking
what I'm saying is those things are like
I quit drinking for 90 days and my skin
got better and my dick got harder and
I'm like
sure but really quitting drinking is the
symptom of a lot of progressive good
changes does that make right but yes but
I think as someone who's about
five months in to nobody auditioning
numbers
um I think you're minimizing how great
it feels
okay fair
yes I might even not be remembering
because I was just like what how much of
a signal does your brain does your body
have to give you when you drink too much
alcohol it goes shut everything down
like get his attention
sound every alarm give him a headache
give him nausea give him diarrhea give
him lethargy give them depression you
know what I mean make it so he can't do
[__] because he needs to get it through
his mind that that was poison yeah and
we're like pair of the dog I'm like [__]
you dude talk about marketing Lie by the
way that's what one of the things that's
come to me and this is so stupid for to
people who have realized it or
especially people who are sober
but one of the things that's come up for
me after trying this on for five months
is oh my God our entire lives we were
sold we were fire hosed with this is how
you have fun that's right on Earth
that's right it's not girls that's right
and with Beach Bodies and with
friendship and camaraderie and the big
game and I know this is so obvious to a
lot of people listening but I don't
think I fully really digested it until I
have had a little bit of a break from
that world because I really this is
going to sound silly but I applaud your
sincerity
and to share that because sometimes the
most obvious things in the world are the
most overlooked things in the world
there's like this Mass hypnosis but I
was like
this is a good time at the beach like I
remember you know drinking a beer and
I'm like this is it
but we were programmed that that's what
I'm saying advertising works it works I
used to put up the absolute vodka
campaign was so cool oh the posters and
I used to collect them that's right and
my parents
didn't object I think they just thought
oh he's appreciating the art of it all
but I would have I had a wall of Vodka
it's Joe Camel you know what I mean it's
like they're trying to think of
something that would appeal to everyone
that will get the seed in them early and
alcohol is one of the most addictive
chemicals in the world and that is one I
always thought you were either an
alcoholic and you had the allergy you
know like you have this disease or you
can handle it and I'm also like well
those things can be true and it's also
true here's a here's a third guy in the
race alcohol's deeply addictive so you
end up needing more yeah you build
receptors in your brain and it takes two
where it used to take one almost
everybody who's drinking is drinking a
little bit more there are anomalies but
usually it grows it gets more and more
and more and more yes and it's someone
who battles anxiety and depression the
idea that I was regularly
pounding a depressant feels a smidgen
idiotic I never I I still don't fully
understand what that means what that
it's a depressant I think it something
to do with your circle circulatory
system like it it's a depressed I don't
know but I don't think it means it makes
you depressed I do it does
I think it causes you a bit of a um uh
it gives you a bit of a dopamine High
yeah that that that has a
a high point that then you can chase
after you've reached it for the rest of
the night you might reach it after two
and a half free drinks depending on your
body weight and then you're striving to
maintain the dopamine high that you got
yeah yeah but all of that
um will lead to a crashing down of a
depression of your mood and system
eventually
it's like you know weed is similar it's
like it was like one out of 30 times
you'd have this like epic like it just
blended with your Chemistry but it was
you you know what I mean that was a big
Revelation for me it's like I was in a
good mood and I had alcohol and then
alcohol is like that wish me and you're
like but then you're in a shitty mood
and you're like this will help and it
like doesn't yeah and you're like and
then it was like well that was on you
like it's never on him and then you look
back and you're like
to me it's a deeply
spiritual thing I think Bliss joy and
just pure happiness just regular
happiness is in your ability to lock
into this moment and not think about the
future not replay the past right and I
think when you're drunk or when you're
stoned or hungover or hung over or in
the middle of binging food or in the
middle of mindlessly playing [__]
whatever a lot of things can rob you of
that and some people find a balance and
they just want a little bit I understand
I can't speak for them I can say for me
it was like hitting fast forward it's
like I can't feel how I feel right now
so I'm gonna drink and like medicate
right and then when I'm and then
tomorrow I didn't know I also didn't
know how to just say no to things so
it'd be like I'm drunk I'm sorry I can't
you know it's like whoops I got drunk it
was like calling in sick for me it was
just a part of how I grew up I mean my
my whole family and friends everyone
just everyone got drunk that's what we
did from the time we were young
teenagers I in my high school I'm really
glad that I died that because that was
how high school was some of the hardest
drinking we did yeah I said we like I'm
a royal some of the hardest drinking we
did the zachness did most of his
drinking in high school no I remember
the kegs and all that in college
obviously but anyway I don't I don't I
don't know that it's forever for me but
I'm enjoying this experiment a lot and
and seeing a perspective on it that I
haven't ever before foreign
I'm so happy that this episode is
brought To Us by betterhelp uh Zach and
I are always talking about how therapy
has changed both of our lives and
getting to know yourself is a lifelong
process especially because we're always
growing and changing like before I went
to therapy I think we talk about this in
this episode I didn't know what
codependency was or how to end a
relationship in a healthy and nice and
kind and helpful way or set up
boundaries with family and people that I
work with but that's what therapy is all
about deepening your self-awareness and
your understanding because sometimes we
don't know what we want or why we react
the way we do until we talk through
things it's greater than the sum of its
parts it's not just talking it is real
help and better help connects you easily
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are because the more
you know about yourself the more easily
you can maneuver through life with less
suffering and more clarity relationships
grief loss anxiety you name it talking
about it with a professional helps full
stop end of story so if you're thinking
about starting therapy give better help
a try it couldn't be easier it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge so discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com weirdo today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo definitely do
that therapy has changed my life also
brought so much more fun into my life is
electric electric
l-e-c-t-r-i-c electric e-bikes summer is
in full swing and guys I am so happy to
say that Val Leela and I have been
spending way more time together Outdoors
as a family enjoying the warm weather
fresh air running errands is now like a
super fun thing to do taking Leela to
school is a super fun thing to do we've
also just been riding getting our
electric e-bikes with our friends around
town it is incredible and it makes
Summer like 50 times better they're so
fun and so happy electric e-bikes are a
sponsor and just in time electric is
bringing you a fast and fresh new ride
the XP 3.0 the 3.0 their latest e-bike
model featuring new hydraulic brakes
snag your electric XP 3.0 e-bike this
month and experience Freedom like never
before I got Val and Expedition
I kind of got it for the family then we
got the plus one seat for Leela she
absolutely loves it I can hear her when
we're on the bike and she goes it's like
flying it warmed my heart this thing is
comfortable well built sturdy and it
runs so smooth you can either turn on
the pedal zest or if any moment you want
you can turn the throttle and off you go
it's the best of both worlds a manual
bike and assistance from the batteries
it's easy it's fun the batteries when I
say really really long time and it gets
us outside in our neighborhood seeing it
at bike speed which is so more beautiful
so much more beautiful and calming
soothing I love it it's fun for Aaron
Aaron's going to the beach going to the
grocery store or just cruising around
town and it's something I can get my
daughter to do I say you want to go on a
ride she always says yes they're created
to make a mode of transportation that's
Transportation excuse me that any one
can ride with quality feature filled
models financed as low as 73 dollars per
month your adventures won't cost a
fortune they include a powerful
removable battery a bright LCD display
7-speed gearing and five levels of pedal
assist to power your ride electric
e-bikes are foldable and ship free fully
assembled so ReDiscover your
Independence this summer with an XP 3.0
from Electric visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com they're so fun
you gotta check it out back to Zacky B
I do there's a book I can't believe it
took me this long to mention it it's
called this naked mind oh yeah I've
heard of that that's crazy yeah if you
read it you'll never there's also well
drinking there's also a um because it's
like why would you stop and then go back
there's a guy who created
um something called um
um
one year no beer is that what it's
called
um
yes I think he has a website that's a
challenge it's like a three-month
Challenge and a one-year challenge all
this stuff and I heard this guy I don't
remember his name on the ritual podcast
and I I think that was really was the
Tipping Point for me I was like
everything this guy says I'm interested
in he wasn't someone who had a an
addiction on the level of he needed to
to go to a program
he but he found that there was a gap
between there there was a plenty of
people out there who were quote unquote
sober curious who didn't need a a per se
maybe they did maybe they discovered
they did and they would do it but but
also those are just like I I without a a
where's there's a there's a gap that's
that isn't being serviced or people who
are like I'm curious about what my life
would be like but they need a thing so
he created this idea of a challenge
because it also has helped in social
situations where there's peer pressure
you could say no no I'm doing he found
this especially with men if you said I'm
doing this challenge they'd be like well
tell me about the challenge and then
they're all like I could do that oh yeah
bro oh good luck on the challenge I
won't make you do the shot then right
cool challenge
we're so dumb so dumb we're so dumb he's
absolutely right framing it in a bar to
Buddies as a challenge helped him uh get
through it because that's what booze is
too booze is a poison and drinking it
and staying on your feet is a way of
peacocking it's showing that you can
drink a poison and still function
sexually that I've said this a million
times
that's what a man
white wine Cosmopolitan what's a guy
drink Scotch something that tastes like
a [__] forest fire and you're like ah
will you show that you can handle it you
know what I love is a Turpin turpentine
on the Rocks I love it
you know a lot of people like this this
the classics but there's just something
about turpentine in the rocks with a
little bit of lime oh my God or a dash
of Pines I'm kidding everyone please
don't try that and soon don't do it
instead try super NS Nirvana it tastes
like cucumbers and lime but make sure
you're ready for it otherwise you'll be
surprised
I still haven't had your magic but drink
it and in 10 minutes you tell me okay I
will because you can be like I don't
feel it you have to shake it up though
make sure you get an experiment for your
audience to see and I will give I will
audience I will not [__] you I will
give a candid I like that you're not
drinking because sometimes I I was on
their Amazon page and some people are
like I don't feel it I'm like I don't
think those people are very embodied
like they're but they might be dealing
with like a hangover or something will
you set a timer how long does it take to
kick in I'd say 15.
where are we in the time by the way
105.
do you edit this down no this is raw
oh baby I like it wrong do you ever cut
things out
only if it's like spoilers
no it's not every once in a while I'm
excited for your fan base to see your
special oh thanks man it's so good you
know what it's called I'm not for
everyone
that's funny
do you do a whole Riff on there or that
I won't share
obviously
but I really thought it was just on on
sexuality that I I hadn't heard spoken
about in that way and it was so this one
what about how dicks aren't gross yeah
the whole riff an area of sexuality and
and
what's what's socially acceptable and
all that stuff I just thought that was
really I haven't heard it I hadn't heard
it uh articulated in that way before and
especially you growing up being a
religious guy I thought that was of all
people to be talking about it I just
thought that was really interesting I
really appreciate that somebody actually
said something nice to me on Instagram
recently and they're like I loved your
new hour and they're like I loved all
the boner stuff and the poop stuff and I
was like when you put it like this it
sounds like I'm JoJo the idiot Circus
Boy I love the bonus stuff love the poop
stuff I love blowing up the [__]
stuff that was great the Hemingway's
stuff did you keep in um the thing where
you uh you just Rift see I saw you
practicing it yeah so I don't it'd be
fun for me to see it to see how much of
the riffs that I saw you kept right or
didn't keep well I I think everything
after the first five minutes of oh that
was probably pure improv you didn't do
the um you didn't keep in when you
played the succession theme song no
there's no piano on the stage no piano
on stage so I didn't do it I love trying
to play the succession play the piano oh
Pokey toe you hit you hit some of the
notes I got it okay I got it okay you
practiced before I had done the bit once
before it's been a great theme song it's
just not a theme song you skip the intro
on
we we skipped it oh I actually I'm gonna
go I'm gonna take a hot take care oh no
I actually think it's kind of stupid the
dad walking around with like VHS Kim and
he's just like walking around in a suit
kind of like like looking mental I guess
I don't really analyze the visuals as
much as I love the melody no the melody
is great I have no notes on the middle
remix I even like remix to Meli and they
play at clubs like under a beat you
could yeah I I even like the shots of
New York City I think that's fitting but
when you get to that like fake like this
is their home video and actually VHS
hanging out in the beds just walking in
the background like get the [__] out of
here I don't know that I I will accept
negativity about succession but I will
here's did I do it that night here's
everybody I love the show everybody on
the show says [__] when they're
thinking they'll go like yeah Dad
um [__] maybe we could do that yeah
it's like I like how shiv always goes
yeah yeah like Yeah question mark yeah
should we do that yeah yeah
wonderful acting it was and all from
most people that we hadn't really this
as a society discovered yet that's true
and I really enjoyed that can I tell you
the Paddington thing yeah there was a
there was a there was a study
it's not a study yes sorry I'm trying to
Circle back you at some point said oh
the study sorry to my audience there oh
the kindness so it was the words that
were imprint it's called imprinting so
if I say kindness if I say gentleness
patience presence I'm imprinting those
words on you and it will literally
affect the way you change uh the way you
behave in the same way that if I say
impatient
tick tock tick tock what are we doing
later like you'll become a little bit
more worth how long this podcast is
going I think that's in my film
um a
good person I I wasn't going into a plug
but thank you a good person now
available to rent everywhere but I do
think it's a 5.99 rental I appreciated
that yeah I have it I have a screener
but I rented it thank you for your 5.99
you're welcome
um I um the spirit of vulnerability and
kindness I think um is is baked into the
screenplay
absolutely to me that's what it's about
absolutely
and I love okay so that's what we're
talking about and that's why I think
people are listening to it and let's get
back to that but I'm going to tell you
this Paddington thing because you're
gonna love it he's the magic lasso can't
show up out of nowhere Paddington saves
himself by walking on top of the Train
by
using candied apples
they that stick he puts his feet on
candied apples and he walks right the
candied apple
is makes its first appearance in that
movie as they're walking through the
carnival on their way to see uh Hugh
Grant give his speech yeah
and it's just perfectly baked in he's
just eating a candied apple
there's no dialogue
any and he go and he gets his hipaws
stuck on it other people are talking and
he accidentally gets it stuck to a woman
who's walking by and he goes well just
looks like a joke yeah but that candy
apple yeah it's satisfying that it comes
back the thing that saves him was
established in the beginning same thing
happens in Paddington one with Doug
you're really selling um to me watching
this master class with Aaron Sorkin I
also just saved you about seven hours of
watching a man in a great suit I bet
there's other um tidbits that are
wonderful it's worth signing up for that
I really do like a lot of his uh his
work oh that goes back to addiction
marrying because Aaron Sorkin always
makes me think of caffeine and nicotine
and just like having a lit up brain so I
hate writing so much it took me 10 years
two things I did I read the war of art
if you read the war of art yes I don't
know that I finished it ironically
interesting I should have gotten my ass
in the chair to finish reading hilarious
yeah that's basically the book it's like
get your ass in the chair but I've been
doing this new thing where I hate
writing my movie and it's been working I
only chew one piece of Nicorette gum
only when I'm writing my screenplay and
oh I write a lot of things I write stand
up I write this I I wanna because
nicotine's so fun you're like well we'll
do it for emails too it's like nope it's
just when you write the screen do you
get a buzz off of it well yeah because
you used to be a smoker no you never
have to be a smoker nicotine is a you
found Nicorette Gum as a you found a
scandal noted you found it
you
love all these guys
noted
foreign
I
don't want to mention two scandalous
comedians but but you know how I knew it
because I'd smoke a cigar every once in
a while and you get a real buzz off of
that I have never heard of someone who
has no addiction to nicotine just going
for just going for the gum you're the
first yeah is it a thing it's a thing
give it a YouTube search because there's
like it's an what am I gonna look at
best ways to chew your nicotine gum you
could say uh medical benefits of
nicotine yeah it's it's a neutrophic it
gets your brain going it gets your blood
pumping and it has a mood elevating part
look at every all the writers out
Stephen King chain smoking there's a
reason it helps your brain function but
it's also highly addictive so I'm like
okay I'm only gonna do it when I write
and guess who hasn't missed a day of
writing I never miss it I can't that's
clever to write that's clever I can't
wait and I don't know that it's healthy
though it it's it's not what is the word
non-carcinogenic it's like caffeine it's
just highly addictive you just have to
be aware that it's highly addictive so
when you go into the store to buy it is
the guy behind the counter like oh good
work man how long you been how long you
quit yeah
and you want to sign up to 35 Mills is
that it yeah that's right I'm the guy
from NYU Film School Northwestern
Northwestern Film School how perfect you
went to an Alfred Hitchcock school to
learn film no it's not based uniform
school is not based on the film do you
know why Northwestern University is
called Northwestern University because
it's north and west of Harvard no
because at the time it was founded
it was in the Northwestern part of the
country
and where is it now just outside of
Chicago
no it hasn't moved the country has
expanded West
yeah it used to be in Portland now where
is it now it's in Evanston Illinois
where it always says oh I like Evanston
good movie theater
yes and a Baha'i Temple
I don't care for them
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding candle
noted just kidding new scandal
what um
what other what other threads are
dangling in the breeze before I bring up
new threads
um I really you were saying kindness in
your movie
yeah kindness and um trying to be
vulnerable and as honest as possible
with my writing so not really putting on
any errors or trying to create anything
uh that wasn't feeling 100 myself and
being sort of fearlessly vulnerable
about it and and for better for worse
that's what I what I wrote yeah the film
okay forgive me if this is stand-ups
don't like when people say how do you
remember all those words you're like
that's not the most impressive thing
about what was happening it's also not
how we think about it so forgive me if
this is the how did you think of all
those words of your movie go ahead but
how did you come about that story
because it is a very
interesting compelling story
do you mind we'll cut this out if you
don't like it but something happens it's
in the trailer you can talk about the
car accident there's a car accident
uh well this this guy's fiance so a
woman who's probably better at this than
you are just because now I'm gonna do it
a woman is driving a car with her future
sister-in-law and her husband she
crashes the car and they both die yes so
obviously we cut forward in time a year
later a year later the wedding is off
yeah this woman now has an opioid
addiction yes she initially was
prescribed opioids for the pain of the
car accident but remained addicted to
them because of the benefits of numbing
her emotional pain and we very like a
good candied apple we've we've uh laced
into the story that there's a
grandfather and a daughter uh and the
grandfather and the woman's fiancee the
her fiance are estranged yeah they don't
talk anymore yeah we did candy apple
that in yeah you candy apple to dinner
meaning like why are they telling me
this yeah come to find out she finally
gets her butt to a meeting and and he's
there too yeah that's just a great story
thank you tell me is that the first
thing what was the first thing that you
went I think I I have a story here was
it that like what if two people went to
a meeting and they knew each other from
was it that or what no I don't even know
I I don't even know I'm sure when you
think about
elements of your stand-up are things
you've written you go I don't even know
what the seed of that was I know well no
in terms of the plot points in terms of
what I the the tone I've I've been very
sad
uh a dealing with grief and loss I've
lost four people in my life that were
important to me in the last four years I
remember your manager I just passed when
we saw yes Chris euvane had had uh taken
his own life right when we had spoken he
was someone who was important to me I
lost my sister to a stroke I lost my
father to cancer
I lost a friend to covid who was living
with me
so I think I just wanted to write about
standing back up after feeling like
you're at your lowest low because like
your care the character in the movie
what is her name Allison Allison yeah
these are the overlooked groups like we
as a society we don't do great with
grief right we don't do great when
someone's down right A A and N A is one
of those incredible places where we're
like No in fact to come in here you have
to be broken yes but for the most part
I remember when this different but when
my first wife and I got split up
somebody at my church actually said that
to me he was like and he was an elder at
the church he was like we actually don't
do great with uh with tragedy the church
yeah he was being very honest not really
hard thing it's not really our thing he
he was saying it like as an apology and
like we need to get better about this
but it really is the broken place is the
basement it's the cigarette coffee
people that are that are doing it so
here you are feeling that and then you
made a movie that sort of addresses well
I wanted to talk about standing back up
after whatever your lowest point was and
I wanted to write it in such a way that
it would be Universal so obviously God
willing most people don't have you know
vehicular manslaughter in their life but
they do have a horrible divorce they do
have the loss of of a little loved one
they do have the loss of a job the worst
breakup they've ever been through being
cheated on whatever it is they haven't
experience where they were on the ground
that's right sobbing
and they have
and or will find a way
to pick themselves back up
no matter what the scale of that debacle
is and I wanted to write about that and
I wanted to write about
um I also have always been interested in
a friendships that are very beautiful to
me that aren't ones that you could have
ever predicted these two people
shouldn't be yeah they would never had
it not been for X Y and Z they never
would have met but we buy it
I buy it I'm saying in the movie yeah I
buy it yeah it's not a spoiler I could
in fact I feel like the movie is so good
in its execution let's not confuse it as
just a story where you go oh and then
that happened like it's the execution
that makes it extra beautiful
she goes to the meeting her ex-fiance's
father is at the meeting yeah Morgan
Freeman she I was in the meeting and I
had a bit of a drinking problem yeah in
the Blackness very good that is very
good thank you that monologue is
incredible thank you
um but he
he she gets up to leave I buy that right
that's worse that's what you would do
and then he's he follows her and says
don't leave and I buy that yes because
not only is he
a man of God like yourself but he is
also someone who's been in AA for a
decade right and service is very
important and knowing how hard it is to
get there is important right and his
first instinct is kindness his first
instinct is no no no no no don't leave
because of me right I know how hard it
is to get here come back right right and
that
see it's one of those things like we've
talked we haven't It's tricky to talk
about this because we have
um
we have issues that need to be dealt
with we have people that need to be
called out you know Harvey Weinstein and
and and the people that we've that have
come up already like there needs to be
accountability I'm with that and there's
also this very special and very human
thing
and we love stories like this when you
can know what somebody's done and love
them and we call that Grace I understand
that there's a perversion of Grace
that's almost like gaslighting like
let's just act like nothing ever
happened crazy Uncle Tony you know what
I mean I've been at tables like that
where we're all that's not Grace this is
like I know what you did and he's like
when she's like are you here because of
me and he's like yes
right he's like I'm not gonna lie to you
first he tries to he tries because she's
she's she says I thought you were sober
and nothing she doesn't fully understand
that people have been sober for years
still go to meetings for just because
they like to and because it helps them
and he says yeah well I started I
stopped for a while and I'm back and
she's and she says is it because of me
is it because of what happened he says
no no no no no she says is it and
finally he gets to the point yes of
course what the [__] do you think of
course I'm here because of the death of
my daughter that was so important so
it's honest it's lights on you know what
I mean like the pile of dog [__] is in
the room that's crazy you know you know
what I mean it's like gaslighting is
let's turn the lights off and just have
Thanksgiving right and act like we don't
smell the dog [__] Grace is like I
acknowledge and of course I'm here you
broke me you hurt me like we have these
feelings but let's try to work through
them and there's something really
beautiful about that I think it's so
beautiful I've never heard this Grace
defined like this so just say it one
more time clear for me because I'm sure
I agree with me because there's
definitely definitely levels of it
there's a poster over there that says
father Greg Boyle said it to me he goes
forgiveness is overrated forgiveness is
I acknowledge that you Zach Braff hurt
me that time
you did do that and I should be mad at
you but I forgive you like it's an act
it's almost like pushing a stone through
a small hole or something grace is just
going like
it's always there like it's Mercy it's
like it's it's not an efforting it's
just like it's a releasing it's a
dissolving there's one of my mantras is
God is the love that I forgive in like
it's not me I'm I'm surrendering it
instead of intellectualizing it and
being like Zach might have been having a
bad day when he was a jerk to me right
and I've Had a Bad Day right so I can
understand that's intellectual grace and
mercy are just like it's like it's clean
air wow I like that stuff that happens
people are just the kind of stuff
they're teaching in church because I am
willing to convert it's deathbed stuff
it's what are we what are we doing
dragging things up and throwing [__] in
each other's faces just just to have an
identity just just to have something to
do you know what I mean then you're on
your deathbed you're like I'm gonna die
at the end of the day I feel like you
should give a TED talk
I'm serious I'll do it no I'm serious
because you're so you're very funny but
you're also I feel like in this you you
touch on this in your new stand-up
special
but I feel like you have wisdom to
impart Beyond just being a funny guy who
drops a few knowledge tidbits in their
stand-up special if you not no no I'm
just saying that there might be a TED
talk or something oh thanks man I'd go I
like it I've been to the Ted conference
have you yeah twice did you enjoy it it
seems like if you'd have to watch six of
them if you don't have to watch them all
yeah and you can come and go
yeah and what's cool about it is that
you meet Fascinating People the people
that are there
are all very accessible you they can you
can be like Oh I'm curious about
um
um you know psilocybin uh for PTSD oh
Jim Smith over here is the leading
practitioner in the country is the guy
with devil sticks
he's just like he's just like going like
this this guy excuse me excuse me Jim
can you the guy that's squidding his
face with his open hand excuse me Jim
I'm sorry to interrupt but can you help
me with my PTSD
have you dabbled in there no I want to
though I'm very curious about it I I did
it recreationally in college and stuff
but I'm I'm very open and intrigued by
the work and research going on with all
of uh uh psilocybin and MDMA and the
others for for depression yeah I I had
ketamine therapy and I I would I I can't
recommend it to you but if you want to
sniff around that bush where is it yeah
this one's getting me there's there's
shampoo there's a there's a you know
there's no gift bag but there's ketamine
on the on the desk I'm not allowed to
tell you to take it but if you want it I
left it there it's just weird that more
than the others and I've done a lot of
different psychedelic ketamine has
become a touchstone for me in my
spiritual practice where I'm like I
understand like you read something like
esoteric and it says something like
we're all one or like we're all saved
together or none of us are saved at all
or if I do something we're all doing it
like weird stuff and I'm like I
completely like I have a part of my
brain that I'm like I I've been there I
know what they're talking about now when
you do excuse me when you do care
Lobster now he's doing it because I'm
burping and uh well Woody Allen is a
burp became a pair of glasses then
became a man
Scandal noted
um
that was the best
skills
I just when you do your ketamine are you
in a therapeutic setting with eye mask
and music you can do that you don't mine
was with a therapist and it was a little
bit more casual right but it was when I
hear was music when I hear about MDMA I
didn't put an eye mask when I hear about
MDMA and um
and psilocybin has been
um that high mask and music that takes
takes one on with a with us with a
protection practitioner I think having a
trained professional makes a difference
and an MDMA definitely can get you to
self-love that's what MDMA is really
special at for me is you go like I've
already said this on the Pod forgive me
everybody but it's like
it's like I S I felt like leaves were
being swept off my walkway to my house
like on the house and we swept the
leaves off and it was like this golden
walkway like I was like oh my God like
you would be like
Zach
shares you know what I mean you'd be
like he feels so much and he shares it
he doesn't want you to be alone yeah he
doesn't want you to feel how he feels
when he's low goes out with it that's
true he risks this is good MDMA I feel
like I'm on it humiliation maybe it's
this [__] thing
it's the magic mind everybody hi I'm
Zach Braff from Magic mind but you will
and and then you write things and you
give roles to other actors you let them
shine like a good person is like you're
welcome actors like these great yeah
they got some great Parts scenes great
Parts not that you know there was a part
of me that was like could Z ZB have been
in this movie but then I'm also like
here's ZB golden golden Street ZB
that's what MDMA does I love you and MD
me and when can we do it together a but
b
um you were surprised that I wasn't in
the film no I wasn't no there was just a
part of me that I do love you thank you
and I like when you're in the movie
thank you I sound like your mother I
feel like I feel like for me this was
so challenging yeah that I that I I
always knew I wanted to have it be
Florence's film and of course Morgan's
film
um I appreciate that and before and be
fully focused on on yeah coach the game
coach the game people were like do you
want to direct your special and I was
like you don't coach a game you're
playing
you're right I think that's a really
good way of putting it when you do when
one does direct themselves in the movie
it is so [__] hard yeah and then when
you switch to not doing it either just
being an actor or just being the
director it is such a Dream It's a dream
it's the ultimate version in my life of
swimming without weights on where you're
like why was I ever doing why were we
doing why were we making more than it
had to be someone sent me a script
recently my my agent sent me a script
and said this is amazing it could be for
you to act in or direct uh even just
reading the the the synopsis of it I was
like I would never do both on this movie
yeah this is Double Black Diamond skiing
I would do one or the other yeah yeah
yeah right right that's this whole time
I was just scrambling for a movie that
was like really basic so I could have
been like so you didn't direct and then
some dumb movie
I couldn't think of it um let's go back
we'll help you directly let's pitch on
what a really funny punchline movie to
that would say something simple
it's hard to not put someone else the
um the Meghan Markle Oprah special
there you go and It's tricky because I
wouldn't be in that doesn't really hold
up you didn't I'm going to all old
movies well I don't direct The Brady
Bunch Movie
this is Double Black Diamond this is
hard because it's period and
that was one of the first movies where I
was like oh not all movies are good one
of The Brady Bunch of movies yeah that
was pretty I made a pretty long
still thinking movies could be turned
movies off
I walk out of movies yeah you walk out I
proudly leave movies yeah do you make us
do you make showings I could see toss my
popcorn down and go
okay I'm gonna give you all a minute to
Google my name my Pete Holmes my dad
used to my dad rest in peace used to
love to let people in the theater know
that he wasn't liking it oh please like
stuff like that
with a big shift in his body and so it
was horrible I loved him to death but it
was so horrible to go to the movies with
him because when he didn't like it he
wanted you to know how much he didn't
like his vote his vote and it's so
cringy when you're when you might be
liking it yeah
I get embarrassed for people that are
liking a movie that I'm hating
like they laugh at stuff and I'm like
what about and we're not going to
mention any titles audience don't worry
but what about when people are raving
and the town and the critics and
everyone's going crazy for something and
you're like what is wrong with me this
is not for me I I'll name some names I
haven't seen them okay you know I don't
think I don't think we want to put down
any artist fellow artists
ever mention anything that we don't like
buddy look it's a beautiful thing to
remind someone to be kind but I wanted
to tell you that I often feel like I
have no interest in sports for the most
part right yeah American Sports I like
tennis I don't like I don't watch let's
just stick with football the American
American football
it's funny because I I directed the
second episode of the whole run of Ted
lasso and I it was the first one with
actual gameplay
and I was the director who was tasked
with figuring out how this show is going
to shoot soccer yeah that's when you go
ODP no no I figured it out you did well
with them we had to the the pitch as
they say
um the soccer field I'm already out by
the way I hate this okay no no no I'm
gonna finish this no no no not this I'm
a director and they go they call the
field the pitch I'd be like [__] get
over it no it's very important to these
people and this in this in this game the
pitch is so sacred that I got to the
field and for the tech Scout and they
said um the greensmen are there who
maintain the the pitch and they said you
can't bring any equipment on this field
and I said what now and they said you
can't bring a single piece of equipment
on this field
and I S and this is an enormous soccer
pitch and I said how are we supposed to
film on it this is and this is not like
something a Steadicam operator could run
around with all day long it's enormous
yeah
so you mean you need a dolly you need
like track I needed track I need a dolly
I needed cranes I needed lights I needed
all the equipment and that you see if
you ever see behind the scenes of a
movie I'm telling your audience I know
that you're familiar
um we needed to put all of that on the
pitch most importantly we had to figure
out a way to move the camera on the
pitch to capture the soccer in in a way
that was fast
that they would go along with
um so along with the cinematographer and
the key grip I came up with this idea
there's these giant tires they often use
on beaches they're like inflatable huge
tires oh yeah you see them um on the
light on the big lights the big heavy
like 20K lights they in order for the
grips to wheel them in sand they use
them but they I we came up with the idea
that if we put a remote controlled
head on on a three-wheeled tricycle
likes vehicle that was not motor
operated but that two grips in soccer
cleats could run with
that the it would be light enough that
it wouldn't touch the pitch or hurt the
pitch at all and the Green's been signed
off on it and it could be remotely
controlled from the sidelines by the
operator and together we all invented
that well and that's how all the soccer
scenes in Ted lasso are shot cut to just
a stogie smoking Jersey crew shooting in
the cemetery willy-nilly hey put
that in 1892. let me just put it on
someone's grave but not the soccer pitch
not your precious little round ball game
I
ain't funny that's true
I didn't know what you're talking about
in series I might just have what it's
like to shoot in the cemetery I saw that
I saw that you didn't get it and I liked
it but I was trying to yes end you but
it took a while to find out where you're
going with it I didn't know if it was a
garden estate reference because my
film's shot in the cemetery oh yeah I
forgot did you catch the Jackie Hoffman
who's the woman who sings once twice
three times a lady yes and also says I'm
the one who made you a shark to try it
on in case you don't leave for another
night
she's the woman yelling [__] boy in a
good place I did notice okay I just
wanted a little little I put a little
Easter egg for you
and I I think I asked you about that the
first time I watched it because she goes
[__] boy that's what they call him get
off get off my laundry yeah no get about
our neighborhood uh you you shirtless
[__] boy no then she goes uh try she
improv this yeah this amazing comedic
actress Jackie Hoffman New York staple
she says try [__] now with your wet
flaccid [__] that's what it is that's
what it was I didn't write that you're
moving so great one last compliment
about your movie because the tension is
so high
that you need these moments yeah and
when they happen you're like ah it's
almost it's like it's salty and sweet
you know I love that it's my favorite
form of of Storytelling is that I'm
going to get you to the point where
there's tears Welling in your eyes
ideally
and then I'm going to make your belly
laugh yeah that's my favorite form of
entertainment personally so I aspire to
do that yeah it's wonderful have you won
Garden State Q I'm not even a huge
Garden State head but here we are go
ahead have you watched it in the past 10
years no I don't really want to watch it
anymore yeah
anyone watch a good person currently
just I think you get to a place where
you're you've seen it so many times well
that was my other question is can you
watch it like have you ever seen Garden
State I don't think you've seen no I
know you have but have you because every
shot of the memory every shot is a
choice every shot is all of a sudden
it's also became such a juggernaut of a
Zeitgeist thing thank God that was
awesome and life-changing but I think
now it's so it just feels
um
sensitive or something I don't I don't
know it's it's I don't want to watch it
there's an Earnest I love that people
love it yeah it's very Earnest it's very
it feels it feels hard on sleeve so I
think yeah it's the first thing I ever
wrote that's what I mean and I was very
young I I this isn't code for there's
mistakes and I'm saying like it's in
Earnest movie yeah and going back to
anything that you made in Earnest in
that age yeah you'd be like you should
see my student films I mean they're
I'm proud of them for what I did at 20
years old but I look at them in cringe
going oh my God what are you doing yeah
I also I remember I'm such a I want to
be an outlier I remember Natalie Portman
being like do something that's never
been done and I remember being like I
wanted your character to go me not doing
this has never been done like me saying
no to your stupid game but that's how
personal that movie was to me I used to
do that that's straight out of my own
life all you would say do something
that's never been done no never told
anyone about it until I wrote it into a
movie but I would to myself
go
no one in the world has ever stood on
this spot made this wacky noise patted
their head done this shimmy like I have
done something that no one has ever done
on Earth and I would just kind of make
myself giggle with that I love it and
then I wrote it in and I wrote Natalie
doing it in the movie that's generous
because you gave that's what you're
doing this is MDMA Zach you took like a
gem and you gave it to Natalie and you
were like but it's for me I mean it's
This brilliant actress doing it for my
story yeah it's the same thing with
Florence and Morgan I'm I'm to me
they're
two of the finest actors alive and I get
to watch them interpret my words that's
that's the coolest thing I've found yeah
about making art that's what old Grady
Gerwig said of all the things she's done
directing someone else saying her lines
was the biggest thrill oh my goodness
what you referenced Florence's AA share
in the movie I mean watching her do that
watching Morgan uh
say lines I've written and he's been one
of my favorites forever yeah
um well
and you know I wish I was here I made a
movie with Manny potenkin and watching a
web Justin always been one of my
favorites watching Manny but tank and
say words Battleship potent nice heart
and I the baby penguin will actually
walk forward I love it you always go
back to penguin you know I I he lost a
bet to me and what was that he had to do
my outgoing voicemail message hello
you've reached hello this is Morgan
Freeman as I can't come to the phone
right now please leave a message can you
play it no it's it's delete been deleted
but this is back when I directed him in
uh going in style
what happened was I played it so many
times that it
it started like getting wore out like a
record I kind of did it got like
degraded I didn't think that something
digital could get degraded but it did
and by the end I was still trying to
show off to people and it was like
what was his Vibe when he did it was he
like or was he like all right I lost the
bet it was in front of the whole crew
the bed was whether he was wrapped or
not and I'm the director so like I know
that this is your last shot he was
wrapped early that day and I said this
is your last shot he goes no it isn't
but yeah it is I promise you're gonna be
robbed early because I'm just the last
shot I needed you and he's like no I
don't believe you and I was like in my
mind I'm like I'll meet you a bet and go
okay
[Music]
and I I was like I'm definitely not
going to lose now I'm not gonna like
unspontaneously add a shot because I
want this [__] message so it was
standing like you know literally uh on
the waterfront in Brooklyn in in front
of like a hundred person crew we like
paused shooting for a second for Morgan
to record my voicemail message
yeah yeah he only really likes to do one
take of anything oh
what happens is you do take one right
and then anyone who knows who's made
anything knows that you go okay that was
a good lesson for us all yeah we learned
a lot we all learned a lot on take one
and now we know that we're gonna move
that there let's close those blinds can
you not put the cup there and hey the
background could you would you mind
walking a little bit sooner and on that
line make sure to everyone the director
has notes for everybody right
but when you direct Morgan Freeman after
take one you go all right uh that was
great let's go again wow
wow
why
just why from the other room why why why
why why
child why while the Penguins will ask
why
I was trying to get in this voice I went
with child and it sounded like the wrong
choice why why hey Zach Zach I have a
quick question hello this is
hello you've I guess I just missed my
friend Andy Dufresne why Andy Dufresne
was a tall drink of water I need a
friend called through six miles of human
feces would he do that no I if I was him
it would be so fun to just yeah I'd be
having dinner we're having dinner we're
trying to talk about stuff Zach cut into
his baked potato with vigor
it's he salted it I learned a lot I got
so many anecdotes out of him but he told
me
um
when we were recording so when you when
you rap shooting Morgan has voice over
in my movie as you know and um you do a
temp track of the voiceover because
you're gonna need it in editing the
assumption is of course you're going to
come back and one day record it in a
perfect sound booth
um
but
you need the you need the voiceover for
editing so you're going to grab it on
set in a little makeshift sound booth
with sound blankets and he told me he
goes you're not going to re-record this
and I said oh really and he goes yes on
Shawshank
um he just uh Frank darabon just used
the temp track because he never he fell
in love with it and that's actually what
happens he's right is that you then go
cut with it for so many weeks and you
fall in love with it guess who that
happened to oh Ben Schwartz Sonic the
Hedgehog he did the temp
and they fell in love with it oh really
like your Sonic that's who you want to
be the temp track
oh I didn't know that sorry I didn't
mean to sideline a captivating Morgan
Freeman yeah
you hijacked a very limited edition
Shawshank Redemption
Sonic the Hedgehog I mean I'm living in
regrets yeah
who doesn't love bench shorts
Hollywood loves bench they do everyone
is every single one isn't he the voice
of of of of the Star Wars roley thing
I don't think that's bb8's voice
he's the voice of some Star Wars
creature
that one yeah what was the other one
well give me another Morgan that I won't
ruin
um anyway so he just so he shows
oh this one's not this one's not done no
just the end is that he was right you
you cut with the voiceover and and it's
and also the actor when they're
recording it even though they've just
wrapped they are so in the space of the
character they're not coming back yeah
four months later and being like oh let
me do this trains arrive on time right
there there's a there's a and also it's
funny you do it traditionally you would
do it it's the last thing oh Morgan's
raps but before you go we just got to
get and so there's they're emotional
they've just delivered this art and the
last thing they're gonna do is this
special little voice over and so it has
this extra magic to it yeah so he was
right we never we we I didn't even I
didn't even record the second week I
didn't want to touch it it was perfect
why
why so yeah part of the job of directing
Morgan is to convince him that there's
going to be more than just one table
wasn't Jack Nicholson than that as well
and why I'm wrong and going in style I
thought that was no it was uh Michael
Cain Alan Arkin
um Morgan Freeman yeah it was a big
movie it was my my only uh Studio film
I've directed and it was
um a enormous circus of of people I
thought you're gonna say failure or
something no no the movie made I think
80 million dollars I mean it wasn't it
wasn't a failure it just I didn't think
it was I was worried for you that you're
gonna be like it's a huge Monumental
circus I was like oh thank God I think I
don't know I was happy for you um I'm
gonna have some weird water
why are you doing this Dave trying to do
Eleanor oh my God Glenn Gary then Ross
yeah
I could use some coffee people come they
take the phones what kind of what kind
of operation they come and they take the
phones you know that this is a humble
brag nothing comes out of your mouth but
bile can I tell you a Hummer right how
[__] up you are I just watched this
movie with Al Pacino which one Glenn
Gary you watched Glengarry with Al
Pacino with Al Pacino was he like I like
this who is this I sat next to him
we sat next to him and watch the movie
what do you mean I'm gonna invite you to
uh a super secret Club
of people who've watched that movie with
Al Pacino no of of Al Pacino
um if you're in this super secret Club
every once in a while gets motivated and
screens one of his films and then does a
little q a after I'll now take your
questions and yeah exactly stupid
[__] [__] was not a riff
by the way glengarry's one of my
favorite movies one of my favorite
movies and I was invited I know Al just
as an acquaintance a little bit I know
that boy Zach Brown yeah and I know him
I know him a little bit just
acquaintancy but I was invited and I
don't I've been to a couple of these I
saw a Godfather one with him and that
yeah
I swear to God I didn't sit next to him
but we're talking about like 30. he's in
the room though dude we're talking about
30 people in a screen here I gotta take
a piss
can we pause
would anyone mind if I pause real fast
that's a pretty good album your Pacino's
better than your Freeman my Pacino is
second to none
he um
anyway on with Glenn Gary oh we also
watched um cruising give me the
Glengarry
well Glengarry I just the only store I
really have is that I sat next to him
which was unique next to him literally
movie theater seat next to him all train
compartments
he's got the best humorous lines in the
movie
um so every time I laughed and I wasn't
playing it up because I was next to him
I was I love the movie I was chaining
live I could catch this is just so
amazing and says so much about us actors
that even if you're Al Pacino and you're
like you're still looking in your
periphery to enjoy the person that's
laughing at your work isn't that
incredible I don't care the god of
Vishnu too on top of it yeah sign the
deal you want to know the first you
never open your mouth until you know
what the shot is you [__] child your
[__] child this is a kind of never
open your mouth until you know what the
shot is you [__] child God couldn't
find his dick with two hands on the map
when I first got out of college one of
my audition monologues would be shelling
the machine Levine the machine telling
telling uh Rick
you should do a one-man Glenn Gower you
can do all the Impressions you got the
memory of a [__] fly I can't do uh Ed
Harris
but you can do a pretty decent lemon red
red
yeah
2306 22 minutes by the kitchen clock not
a word not emotion is my arm getting
tired no I did it and he's going like in
the old days like I used to do like like
you taught me well there you go and he
goes wow and then proceeded as well if I
did if I did
no sorry great sales Sally no sorry I
[__] up the characters he goes he goes
I think Pacino goes to Lemon like you
taught me and he goes no well yeah
that's right no well if I did yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah dude why are we not best
friends I don't know I don't know I
would we have the exact same interest I
know and there's a weird Jersey Boston
thing happening like like like sensitive
boys from kind of rough neck places does
that is roughneck yes I just mean tough
places yeah I went to a tough High
School people would beat the [__] out of
each other after school Just for kicks
they would get in a fight you would just
hoped that you were never on the list of
someone who was going to be beat up
who books that I don't know but
someone's watching some fights at your
school not too many my nightmare was
like that it would ever happen that it'd
be like you know it's spread through the
school you see here who's fighting who's
fighting yeah it's gonna be uh Zach
there was scheduled fights which I never
understood yeah after school it was like
this kid and this kid are going to fight
everybody would always try to stop it
I'd be like why don't you just not go or
like apologize you have to show up you
gotta show you I'm also here to say you
don't have to show do you think your
your listeners would mind if we just
keep presiding Glengarry to each other
I'm trying to think of other lines well
the first line in the movie is 2306
please it's his daughter's hotel room uh
hospital room I love that monologue
which Kelly the machine has about
recounting proudly his sale rebate no at
the end of the movie when he's about to
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I'm trying to remember how it goes
but he talks about how he sits with the
couple
and he says now Harriet and blah blah
how is the time now is the time hold up
man 23 minutes 22 minutes by the kitchen
clock he's holding his hand there for 22
minutes for 22 minutes he holds his hand
yeah 22 minutes by the kitchen's like
not a word not emotion is my arm getting
tired now I point back to the living
room to a sideboard I didn't even know
she had a sideboard I didn't even know
what his sideboard is no no she brings
up the shot glass with the little yeah
with the pattern and he goes no doesn't
he say like [__] knifeboards or
something like that yeah I forgot it I
didn't know I didn't I didn't even know
there was a sideboard yeah I point to
the living room to the side where I had
the little shot glasses
oh there's a part where he goes she
brings out uh coffee cake and he goes
[__] her he goes homemade and he goes
from the store he goes [__] her [__]
I say now
is the time they signed they signed
Ricky like in the old days
I did it I did it like in the old days
uh like I was taught then he says like
YouTube you taught me well if I did yeah
yeah and then it finally and it goes get
the chalk get the Chuck Williamson and
it's just like a play the tone chain
what about this guy the spell has been
Scandal acknowledged Scandal
acknowledged I'm trying to run an office
here now will you go to lunch go to
lunch will you go to lunch
pretty good right
when he puts the gum in Scandal
acknowledged Scandal acknowledge we're
talking about Kevin Spacey for people
who don't know but he puts in the gun
imagine this podcast got very boring
people that don't know Glenn Gary I
don't care no I I was doing Kevin Spacey
saying I don't care well
what time is it
oh yeah oh [__] oh [__] I gotta go yeah
we all have to go well thank you for
having me let me just send this text uh
oh [__] buddy wait you're gonna cut this
out is there a brief cut out One Moment
no I like these moments this is when
they order breakfast on Comedians and
Cars it's always the best part how does
Zach text he's a double thumb guy he
holds it both hands
looks very
sharp line like that all right listen I
really do think you'll like the shampoo
your hair looks fantastic thank you you
recommended a cafe where I'm gonna meet
a friend and no don't wash your hair
that's the problem that's that's the
shampoo for guys that don't wash their
hair I'm telling you you wreck this is
gonna [__] up my hair because it's not
shampoo here it's it's non-shampoo
shampoo this isn't even an ad they're
not even paying for this [__] this is a
gift for you if your secret is don't
wash your hair this is how you wash your
hair is this a sponsor of your show it
is but it's because I love them
okay I'll try it you can I've tried
everything else you're gonna know that
that calmed me down I think you're kind
of kind of Jazzy I think it might be
psychosomatic I think that your kindness
I think that your kindness
my sales force I just want to come over
here once a week and just sit here we
don't need the mics and just quote
Glengarry with each other can we watch
it can we make a day to watch it wanna
watch it without I'll try and get out
no in all seriousness you can join the
super secret Club I'll get you in
you've missed Godfather Godfather 2
cruising and Glengarry we should do son
of a woman
the history of my skin by Charles Sims
audition for that part really yeah well
did you get it not for Alice part for um
Chris Chris
what's his name Robin
Robin his name is not Chris Robin he
became robin though Christopher Robin
Chris O'Donnell there was a time when
Chris Chris O'Donnell was going to be
Matt Damon but then Matt Damon became
Matt Damon Chris O'Donnell do you
remember about the part and when I saw
what he did he was wonderful in the
movie I I um said oh my audition wasn't
that good
well I had some Clearasil my roommate
gave me
that's when he says the history might
scan by Charleston I I had a Tumblr
called the history of my skin by Charles
Zimmerman I think that movie holds up
that movie means a lot to me I love that
movie but I haven't seen it in over a
decade that movie was my first like
Father Figure like and my dad used to
take me to New York and it made a big
difference in my life like because New
York's so scary and he like took me into
the city and parked a Winnebago in
Staten Island and was like who cares I
was like just pure confidence he really
taught me a lot and and then I saw that
movie I wrote my dad a two-page
single-spaced letter on an Apple 2gs
just thanking my dad for teaching me how
to be confident after I watched that
movie that's beautiful isn't that
beautiful that's what movies can I tell
you my conundrum yeah
um I asked you if there was a cafe where
I could meet a friend over in this area
of town until the all-time yeah and um
and I just we're running late which is
great because I could talk to you all
day but um I said okay all time Pete
suggests all time yeah the person just
texted me and saying hey there's a line
waiting out front they're closed because
it's between lunch and dinner oh okay uh
well I'll take you to another place I'm
also meeting a friend out front and
we'll walk somewhere but you've you've
you've there's a human being that's
standing on a curb because of you [__]
from the store I love uh being on your
show and I love hanging out with you I
love it can we be friends in real life
yeah I really only do this to come hang
out with you
what do you think we care about
promoting a movie or money do check out
a good person I we do we do we do I just
mean like you're you're an always-on all
right would you say it that's what I
have to say yeah how do I say it
well you were the voice in uh Chicken
Run yeah
oh sorry I have to summon uh chicken
Bill hold on the sky is falling keep it
crispy
one guy just came so hard I'm just like
God
[Music]
thank you